Well we already know that
definite integrals can help us
figure out areas underneath
curves or between curves.
What we'll show in this video
is that you can actually use
pretty much the exact same
principles to figure out the
volumes of rotational solids.
So what do I mean?
So let me just draw a
couple of examples.
So let me start with a fairly
straightforward function.
That's my y-axis.
This is my x-axis.
Let me draw my function.
I'm going to draw y equals the
square root of x, but I'll keep
it general right now, just so
this applies generally
to a lot of things.
So y equals the square root of
x looks something like that.
It keeps going.
Actually, let me redraw that,
because I didn't want it
to curve down like
that at the end.
It goes up like that,
and then it just keeps
going up like that.
That's better.
OK.
So we'll call that f of x.
This is our x-axis.
This is our y-axis.
And we already know that if
we wanted to figure out
the area under this curve
between two points.
Let's say between the point
a-- well, we can do it
between any two points.
Let's say this point a and this
point b, and we wanted to find
this area between
the two curves.
I'm drawing everything
crooked today.
Let me do a different color.
If we wanted this area right
here, we would essentially just
be-- just as a review-- be
summing up a bunch of small
squares, where each square has
a bunch of rectangles, has a
width dx, and its height at
that point would be whatever x
value here is-- it
would be f of x.
And if we take the sum of all
of these areas, of all of these
rectangles, we would get
the area to this curve.
And we learned in the definite
integral video that that's just
equal to the definite integral
from a-- that's a lower bound--
from a to b of f of
x times d of x.
Where each [? rafter ?]
angle is f of x times d of x.
And hopefully this makes a
little bit of intuitive
sense to you.
I think a lot of people go
through calculus just learning
how to do it mechanistically,
just learning you know how to
do it like a robot without
really understanding
necessarily what's going on.
And if you understand what's
going on, you'll never be
really lost when you see
something a little bit
different than what you
might have practiced.
So with that out of the way,
let's think about something.
What if we took this
function and we rotated
it about the x-axis.
So this might take a little bit
of visualization, but what you
imagine is-- let me
see if I can draw.
So I take this curve and if I
were to rotate it about the
x-axis, it would look
something like this.
It would look like a
sideways copper vase.
It would look like that, where
that would be the opening.
That would be the
opening on the inside.
I can even shade it.
Show you my drawing skills.
OK.
Hopefully that make sense.
You know, that would be the
y-axis there, and the x-axis
would pop out the middle.
That's if you took this and
you rotated it around.
So let me draw an arrow to show
that we're rotating it around.
And if we did that, what would
be the volume created by--
well let's use the same
boundaries, between a and b.
So if we took this piece and we
rotated it around, what would
it look like between a and b.
It would look
something like this.
Let me see if I can draw it.
So you would have a-- whoops,
I'm not trying that well.
This is really testing the
limits of my ability to use
this computer to draw things.
It'd be kind of a circle on one
end, and then it would curve
down a little bit and it would
be another circle
on the other end.
And if I were to draw the
x-axis, the x-axis would
kind of pop out of the
middle right there.
That right there would be
the point b, x equals b.
If we were to kind of go behind
or look into the object we
would see the other surface
of this rotational solid.
And this point right
here, that would be a.
That would be a.
And then of course the x-axis
would keep going, and then
that would be the y-axis.
The visualization really
is the hardest part
about these problems.
So first just actually
imagine what you're doing.
So I just did this section, if
I rotated it about the x-axis.
But if I were to draw the whole
curve, the whole curve would
look something like this.
It would look something
like that, and we're
just rotating it around.
Hopefully that makes sense.
We're rotating it
around that way.
So how do we do that?
Well we use the exact
same principle.
When we figured out the area,
we would figure out the area of
each of these small squares,
and then we would take the sum
of an infinite number of
infinitely small squares,
and we got this.
So to do the volume, what we
do is instead of having each
rectangle, we kind of rotate
each of these rectangles
around the x-axis.
If that's the rectangle,
it has width dx, and
it has height f of x.
So this height right here,
that's f of x at this point.
If I were to rotate this
rectangle around the x-axis,
what do I end up with?
Well I'll end up with a disk.
Let me see if I can draw
that reasonably well.
I'm trying to show you some
perspective when I draw.
So that would be the top
surface of the disk.
And this would be the
side of the disk.
And so this is the top
surface at the disk.
And what would be the radius
of this disk, what would
be this height right here?
Well that radius, that's
going to be f of x.
That's this height.
Imagine if you took this and
rotated it around, that's the
same thing as this height
right here, right?
So that height or the radius
of the disk is f of x.
And then what's the
width of the disk?
Well that's just d of x.
That's the same thing as this.
We just rotated it around.
So what would be the
volume of this disk?
It would be the
area of this side.
It'll be this area right
here times this height.
Well what's the area?
Well we know the radius, right?
Area is equal to pi r squared.
What's this radius?
My radius is f of x, right?
So the area of this disk is
equal to pi times the radius
squared, it so it's pi times f
of x, the whole thing squared.
So what would be the volume
of this entire disk?
So it'll just be
this area times dx.
I'm running out of
space and colors.
So the volume of that disk is
going to be equal to area of
that disk, pi f of x squared.
The whole function, whatever
length this is at any point
squared, that gives us the
area, times the depth you
can say, so that's d of x.
Now that gives us just the
volume of this one disk
when it's rotated around.
So if we wanted the volume of
this entire object that I drew
here, we would just sum up
a bunch of these disks.
We would take each of these
rectangles, rotate them around,
figure out the volume of that
disk it creates, and
then sum them up.
And so essentially we're going
to take an infinite sum of a
bunch of these small
little disks so we can
take the integral.
So this is the volume
of each disk.
We could call that a
volume of a disk.
So what's the volume
of the whole thing?
Well we just take a sum,
an integral sum of
each of these disks.
So the volume when you rotate
it is going to be equal to the
definite integral between-- and
remember, our boundaries were a
and b-- between a and b of this
quantity right here--
pi f of x squared dx.
So hopefully that
makes sense to you.
Just remember, this is
the width of each disk.
This is the radius of the disk,
or the radius of the surface,
so it would be squared, and
that makes sense, that's
the height, f of x.
And we have pi r squared, so
that's where the pi comes from.
Some people just memorize that.
I don't recommend you do that,
and we'll see that later.
But I'm out of time.
In the next video I'll
actually apply this
to an actual problem.
See you soon.